hello viewers welcome to elim TV a
station where you watch learn and also
interact your tutor is Mr an agriculture
teacher in today's lesson we in form one
lesson 24 topic Crop Production one it
deals with land preparation subtopic
importance of land
preparation on to the lesson objectives
by the end of this lesson you should be
able to number one explain the various
tools and equipment used during land
clearing then number two State the
various methods of land uh clearing
terms used we have land preparation and
and what is land preparation these are
the various activities that are carried
out in the farm to prepare the land or
to make the land suitable for planting
or the land to to be ready to receive
the planting material then we have the
land the some of the activities which
are carried out we have during pre land
preparation the first one we have land
clearing and this refer to the cutting
down all the vegetation uh cover on a
particular piece of land then we have
the primary cultivation and secondary
cultivation primary cultivation refer to
the initial opening of land in a virgin
land or uh the the the initial opening
of land uh following uh land uh clearing
then we have secondary cultivation it
entails uh the process of U hallowing or
uh seed bed refinement whereby the
farmer normally uh goes back to the
field after carrying out primary
cultivation and breaks down the large
soil cloths into small pieces so that
you can establish a fine H til which
will promote uniform germination and
also uniform depth of uh planting then
uh we have the methods of land clearing
the first method you uh you we have the
tree Fairing and during tree fairing you
can use various method uh for those
people who uh have doing land clearing
on large scale they can uh uh uh cut
down the trees using the bulldozer and
that is a a a machine uh which is uh
well displayed there and and you can as
well as use for the small scale Farmers
they can use an ax to cut down or to
during tree failing and also you can use
a power so or electric so whenever it
comes to tree faing as the method of
land clearing then we have the second
method we have burning method but this
method is not advisable why uh because
it will end up lowering the soil
fertility because the high temperature
which is induced it will cause the soil
microorganism which are very very
beneficial uh uh to the plant also to
die due to high temperature so it is
very very uh it is not advisable for you
to use this method then we have uh the
slashing method as you can see it is
well Illustrated here you can use a
slasher also you can use a panga when it
comes to uh
slashing of the vegetation cover then we
have the fourth method is chemical
method in chemical method we normally
use the chemicals that are sprayed in
the farm in order to mitigate the pro
the problem of the vegetation cover and
therefore all the vegetation cover will
be will die at the end as a result of
being affected by the chemicals which
are normally used what are the factors
that necessitate land clearing one
whenever you are uh you you are
preparing a virging land remember
virging land is the one which has never
been ctiv has never been cultivated
before and therefore it is bushing and
therefore you have to carry out land
clearing then the second one previous
crop uh if the previous crop was a stamp
was made up of some stamps and therefore
the the the it we necessitate land
clearing for example maze if uh the
previous crop of maze uh you should
carry out land clearing in order to pave
way for the subsequent operations such
as primary and secondary cultivation
before planting is done then we have
interval between primary and secondary
cultivation some Farmers normally carry
out primary cultivation then there is a
very big gap in between the primary the
time when the primary is done and the
secondary done it means that there is
the growth of the crop of the weeds
again in the field and therefore it
necessitate for land clearing to be done
and also where the land has left follow
has been left follow for a long period
of time if the land is left
uncultivated condition in uncultivated
condition for a period of 2 years uh it
necessitate uh land clearing uh to be
done first before the other subsequent
operation to be exercised then we have
tools which are used or the machine the
tools equipment or machine which are
used during land clearing we have a
slush you can use aanga you can use a
matchet you can use buza and also you
can use a power so what are the reasons
for land clearing number one to kill the
wind and number two to reclaim the land
this is to make uh uh land useful the
land which was not useful after you
carry out land clearly it becomes useful
then to facilitate finally it is to
facilitate easier carrying out of
subsequent operation such as primary
cultivation and secondary cultivation we
have come to the ends of today lesson
and the questions uh which I'm going to
uh assign you is there inform of
assignment the first question is list
any four types of tools and equipment or
machine used during land clearing then
the second question State any three
reasons for carrying out land clearing
then number three mention any three
methods of land uh clearing then for
reference you can refer from the
secondary agriculture student book one
and the publisher is the Kenya
literature Bure then for more
information you can reach us at elim TV
through the following addresses the
first one you can use SMS at uh using
the number which is well displayed for
you you can use the YouTube at elim TV
and also Facebook platform at elim TV
and finally you can tweet us using uh at
elim
tvk thank you for joining me in this
lesson please stay tuned till next
lesson bye-bye